the inferno was scattered fragments of
plane and debris burning over a large
area in the moments after impact in the
light of day the scale of this accident
was revealed across farmland on the
outskirts of Tehran among the wreckage
still smoldering poignant insights into
the lives that have been lost and ranks
of body bags containing the remains of
the dead but say eyewitnesses the death
toll could have been even worse does
that money go by them when I arrived the
plane and passenger bodies had been
shattered into many pieces the only
thing that the pilot managed to do was
steer the plane towards a soccer field
near here instead of a residential area
back there a crash near the field and
into a canal in Ukraine mourners brought
flowers to honor the dead while its
government announced an end to flight to
Iran for now in the wake of the tragedy
daughters for white Deborah chin we
decided to suspend all the activities of
all Ukrainian aviation companies in
Iranian airspace until the causes of
this tragedy have become clear there
were 167 passengers and nine crew
members on board the flight to Ukraine
at that 82 people were Iranian 63
Canadian 11 Ukrainian 10 Swedish for
Afghan and 3 German with the same number
of British dead they were Saeed Thomas a
B and Sam's Akai both engineers an
entrepreneur Mohammed CAD Coda's a day
from Brighton investigations have begun
the black box flight recorder has been
recovered Iranian authorities say it
won't be given to plane manufacturer
Boeing but may be passed on to
authorities in another country flight
accident experts say the evidence so far
is inconclusive but they said indicates
a horrendous impact the degree of
breakup suggests a high vertical speed
I'm unclear about the horizontal extent
of the wreckage putting that together
there's clearly been in loss of control
and
ie a high-speed ground impact there is
so far no evidence linking the crash
with the crisis engulfing Iran or the
missile attacks carried out further to
the west in Iraq but there are major
questions to be asked how did a plane
with a solid safety record simply fall
out of the sky just after takeoff with
such a huge loss of life Dominik Waghorn
Sky News